o
Olá muito boa tarde eu estou um bocado
derramado na quer dizer depois no Altas
Horas minha apresentação vai ser um casa
tem que foi muito final gostei nessa
desde já queria agradecer ao Frederick a
Anna pelo convite É uma honra estar aqui
diante de vocês e então eu uso dos
convidados queremos pedir uma pequena
coisa que vocês tirassem os cadernos que
sofresse e tivessem está à disposição
porque eu amei vou pedir para fazer um
pequeno exercício mais ou menos
queria fazer um pequeno preâmbulo o ao
está gigante
mais devagar faz favor
outra coisa
eu queria só começar a falar como é que
eu cheguei este tema porque tem uma
relação com palavras
e o geralmente o meu processo criativo
é muito baseado em palavras porque elas
são muito condensados em termos de
conceito e podem representar muita coisa
com algumas letras e isso é muito
interessante para uma pessoa que está
habituada a criar imagens porque tem que
lidar com muito menos elementos E desde
que eu recebi este convite para estar
aqui a vossa frente fui fazer criando
uma lista muito grande de temas queria
partilhar faz hoje precisamente um ano
que defendi Minha tese e portanto eu não
tenho assim agora nos conselhos de vida
para os agentes ensinar ou partilhar
portanto
a Mas o início de setembro eu recebi um
e-mail da organização e muito curioso
estava lá uma palavra como um relâmpago
e
o obrigou a pensar num tema
para mim fizesse sentido partilhar e
isso foi vulnerabilidade eu comecei a
pensar o que é vulnerabilidade para mim
sem ser extremamente lamechas e
acaba por ser os meus livros dos vossos
que são um sítio muito pessoal e
fazem parte de mim eu como todos vocês
comecei a desenhar quando era mesmo
Pequenino muitas vezes em casa dos meus
pais em casa dos meus avós nas férias e
tudo mais às vezes porque não tinha
ninguém para brincar então foi passar o
tempo a fazer isso e também era para
para viver mais intensamente os mundos
de entretenimento que que eu gostava
muito represente perfeitamente de fazer
cópias de Dragon Ball a torto EA direito
que é que nos fez mais tarde do Pokémon
etc etc todos os jogos de cartas que eu
gostava e esses mundos que me envolvia
imprimiu atrás a
benção está à frente de fim de um ciclo
também tive assim que no interesse em
grafites e coisas do gênero
e fim do ciclo e tem que fazer as coisas
que nós todos temos que fazer para que
agrupamento é que eu vou eu eu gosto
gostava e gosto muito de animais e
decidir fazer como ter o melhor erro da
minha vida que foi e paciências
fui paciências o primeiro vez um ano foi
bom porque até eu conseguir empenhar
estar interessado de que a ciência
estava muito viradas para Paris
essências naturais
Mas a partir do 11º para a frente a um
pequeno problema porque o passo que a
programação toda a virar para dentro
para nós como seres humanos e
sinceramente
eu gosto de menos mas não se esqueça de
saber como é que as mitocôndrias fazem
energia né porque assim Dirigir à
é
finito comecei a fazer a desenhar outra
vez não tá passar do tempo das aulas fiz
inúmeras bandas desenhadas com os meus
amigos e como pessoas que eu não gostava
e pronto foi uma coisa que me Manteve
Manteve
ligado porque eu tive que fazer o décimo
décimo dessa pronto secundário todo em
ciências e terminal e eu nunca fui um
aluno exemplar em termos académicos eu
entre os meus amigos tinha sempre notas
altas e olha sempre aquela que estava a
ler arrasar os dozes 1110 eu lembro
perfeitamente só para me divertir no 11º
ano eu tinha uma professora extremamente
rígida as ciências e o que é que eu
decidi fazer o teste todo ao contrário
ou seja começar a última pergunta e
acabar na primeira ou seja justo ficava
as perguntas primeira aqueles grupos em
que temos que justificar primeiro depois
da resposta porque ele ficava primeiro e
paz a resposta uma professora que era
assim rígida que eu dava em casa da
cabeça e eu divertiam claro ouvir a
minha
parte feito isto continuar a desenhar a
continuar envolvido em mundo da
intercement a parte e eu quero salientar
mesmo isto porque
para os meus pais ver um rapaz assim
meio perdido demasiado distraído com
outras coisas e eles pensavam obviamente
como qualquer pai que se preocupa
pensava que ele estava a perder e não
esse mundo Sophie ao cabo representavam
também era uma manifestação de desenho
porque esse mundo sentimentos começam
todos todos no seu processo de produção
é começa a 1 com o desenho são artistas
que desenvolvem o mundo toda a volta
personagens a história e eu também
pronto a mais uma vez continua e
desenhar continuar estar envolvido
nesses mundo a e foi isso por dentro do
meu grupo de amigos de ciências Eu
também ganhei a minha identidade através
do desenho Era o miúdo que estava lá
atrás a dormir e acordava para os vosso
e pronto e era assim que eu me
identificava que eu me seria no meu
grupo Pronto acabei o secundário fui
para partes aqui em Coimbra e a partir
daí comecei a conhecer temperatura e fui
parar em lustração tirando uma
licenciatura em design gráfico e
mestrado em ilustração
e o desenho agora neste preciso momento
é muito mais já não uso tanto para viver
os mundos entretenimento Mas mesmo muito
para viver o mundo exterior porque o as
minhas obras eu tenho duas obras que em
Coimbra que estão à vista do público que
é o Moral
e no mercado a lua Costa a minha e no
ativar sangue na sala da árvore um
desenho do robô é meu e esses essas
obras possuem um caráter muito realista
e para para eu conseguir imbuir as
minhas obras dos meus desenhos com esse
Realismo eu preciso de observar
os efeitos da luz
ou as suas formas como é que elas
interagem com o meio ambiente e com o
todos os cinco sentidos conseguir
absorver aquele tudo e consegui
expressar espero eu tenho um dele
desenho eu pronto eu queria feito agora
fazer o exercício no instante eu peço
por favor a todos muito rápido que me
desenha uma casa mais rápido que vocês
conseguir se faz favor
E aí
G1
o corte está quem é
E aí
e já está
quantos vocês aqui desenhar uma casa
assim como desenhar um quando era miúdo
que que acontece
o desenho de observação também serve
para quebrar esse tipo de simbolismos
que nós temos quebrar ou construir sobre
porque muitas vezes o que não
consideramos Óbvio ouviu é devido a
nossa percepção e a nossa percepção pode
construir os tipos de símbolos até muito
infantis por vezes que nos podem
enganar para se dizer outra coisa que o
desenho de observação serve muito bem é
para alimentar nossa imaginação nossa
imaginação é uma máquina potente cima da
mas só precisa de constante combustível
esse combustível serve para nós não
discutimos se vocês repararem desenhar e
continuamente Só através da vossa cabeça
você nota um padrão e começam a repetir
imenso esse combustível serve para
prevenir esse tipo de repetição e também
informar ainda mais a nossa imaginação e
fazer outro tipo de associações
e portanto eu uso também o livro dos
vossos como meio de explorar a minha
imaginação furar o mundo por exemplo
para o mural da do mercado eu tive mesmo
que comprar uma boa eu comprei a Lula
pular minha frente e eu tenho o caderno
teu uma data dos vossos Laboratórios
como um esboço final daquilo que que lá
está e foi mesmo Tentar conhecer como é
que eles bate que formas é que compõem
uma lua que tipo de textura que tem para
depois poder informar o meu desenho Como
já disse o sketch book O Livro dos
vossos serve para explorar o mundo e
para também
ter a minha identidade como estou afora
sou eu que estou lá como é que vai dizer
e eu não mandei buscar lá fora mas a
cabeça e faz parte da minha identidade
outra coisa que quis sabe bastante bem é
por nós como artistas precisamos de
experimentar nós não não temos um
processo exemplo pronto é isso que eu
faço o tempo todo a partir de agora
temos ver isso seria a morte do artista
basicamente e Há muitas abordagens nem
que seja para o mesmo tema eu neste
momento não sei se vocês já repararam
mas acho que é a parte mais que um gato
no já pronto a minha gata que serve
bastante de modelo e
todos os desenhos que estão lá da minha
gata diferem ou numa escolha de material
ou na maneira como represente ou tipo de
linhas que tenho ou composição mesmo na
página porque porque desenho e pintura
de dobras em vários
digamos escolha Oi Paulinha só cores o
rosto mais ou
ou composição da página e sempre que
inicia um desenho tem que sempre essas
coisas todas a minha frente
o que faz o desenho especial eu tipo de
coisa que eu que decido seguir e as que
eu decidi tirar a Podemos até fazer o
jogo da restrição sendo 15 bolinhos e
uma mancha deixa-me tentar comunicar um
objeto a uma ideia um conceito
isso é muito importante para estarmos
constantemente a
explorar
EA experimentar que está outro jogo o
final
de modo e uns para frente não nos
estagnar nos num patamar só
a
e é muito engraçado porque acaba por ser
uma eu já já como esse se meio uns 50 e
poucos livros destes de vários formatos
e tudo e é engraçado eu ir aos antigos
estar tipo
constantemente após tipo fazer a tomar
desenhado
depois de fazer estas comissões todas as
sempre um pequeno pormenor de um desenho
num canto da página que ficamos tão mas
isto até tá interessante
deixa-me aqui pegar nisto inserir outra
vez nos nos meus desenhos mais atuais
portanto acaba por ser uma linha não uma
linha evolutiva
não diria uma linha porque uma linha
principal em caminho reto não é um
caminho reto mas é
alguma marca da nossa evolução
e
para concluir
o livro de voces para mim
e é uma manifestação física da minha
paixão pelo dizem que meu irmão tem uma
piada corrente eu nunca sabe onde é que
eu estou a trabalhar quando é que eu
estou a descansar porque sempre dizer é
verdade é essa
e eu nunca sabe é sempre uma incógnita e
Como disse além de ser uma expressão
física da minha paixão pelo desenho
e é no mundo corrente onde a tecnologia
tem
tem grande valor está sempre na na
frente da cabeça das pessoas
esta tecnologia
ajuda-nos a sair de casa sair nós
próprios que nós temos muita tendência a
ficar dizer-nos como é ouvir mas
ajudamos a sair da cadeira sermos menos
acidentários é uma grande eu tenho pena
da minha gata porque ela sempre quer
brincar o teclado do computador
ajuda-nos a sair de casa e explorar o
mundo
ah e também
E também o que eu acho que
a
ajuda se expor ao mundo e ajuda-nos
pronto a partilhar com as outras pessoas
e nós a sua experiência nossa vida
porque nem toda a gente tem mesma
percepção do real eu trouxe uma data de
livros dos vossos por favor aquilo
Episódio Se quiserem ver eu convidas a
ver os desenhos estão à vontade e por
favor peço que que façam isso e Pronto
acho que é isso eu posso concluir que
e
vai aqui ó
E aí